morning everyone live on the picket
lines in just a moment as half a million
people go on strike today first let's
bring you the latest on the mystery of
the missing mom who vanished walking her
dog in Lancashire the case of Nicola
bully making the front pages of many of
this morning's newspapers what on Earth
has happened to a police have spoken to
a possible witness the 45 year old was
last seen on Friday morning her mobile
phone was found on a bench near where
she was last seen and said Michael's on
wire in Lancashire it was still
connected to a conference call when it
was found her dog Willow was also found
loose between the river and the bench
officers say the investigation remains a
missing person's inquiry and there is
nothing at the moment to suggest
third-party involvement in her
disappearance you can see Frogman are
searching the rivers nearby her partner
Paul says the situation is just
Perpetual hell he said he and his young
daughters are living through this but it
doesn't feel real all we can say is we
need to find her she's got got two
little girls that need their mummy home
Nicholas friends had this to say
you go from being hopeful to being
heartbroken to being and just trying to
be strong because all we want is to find
her she's got two little girls wanting a
mummy so anybody's got any any
information please just come forward we
don't know what why she's missing where
she is we just want her home
Lancashire police are calling on anyone
who may have seen her on Friday morning
anyone who's got dash cam footage that
may pinpoint her to a certain spot to
get in touch with them two little girls
want to know where their mummy is
to strikes now in thousands of schools
are shot trained services are canceled
and disruption is also expected at
airports and at universities there's
Britain braces for the biggest day of
strike action in a decade teachers train
drivers civil servants and Border force
staff are involved in a coordinated
series of walkouts the government is
warning of significant disruption
so around 500 000 workers will stage
strikes across the UK no region will be
unaffected teachers belonging to the
National Education Union will walk out
from more than 23 000 schools in England
and Wales the union says 40 000 new
members have joined since it announced
six days of strikes members of the
Education Institute of Scotland are
striking in Aberdeen and also Cloud
manager parts of the week
um we're told as part of their Regional
strikes and more than 70 000 staff at
150 universities in the UK are taking
strike action with the university and
college Union a hundred thousand civil
servants in the public and Commercial
Services Union will walk out in 123
government departments the biggest Civil
Service strike in a decade thousands of
rail workers from asleff and also from
the rmt unions are on strike again with
14 operators affected and the trades
Union Congress or TUC is leading a march
on Parliament as part of a nationwide
protest against new laws to limit strike
action
and we'll be covering every angle with
our correspondence right across the
country Alice Porter is at London's used
to station phrase and Maude is at a job
center in Leeds and Dan Whitehead is
standing by for us at a school in
Cardiff ladies first what's happening in
central London and morning
good morning to you yes members of the
aslef Union which represent about 96 of
train drivers come across the country
are striking today this is the seventh
day of industrial action that they've
taken over the last 12 months or so and
this is very much over a long running
dispute overpay the rail delivery group
they put forward a backdated four
percent payoffer for last year and four
percent for this year but that's been
rejected by asleff they say the terms
and conditions associated with it make
it unacceptable they're wanting
something in line with inflation and
that's why we're seeing industrial
action today and Friday which means only
about 30 percent of train services will
be operating across the country
okay thank you Fraser the situation
where you are
the civil servants on strike today from
over 120 different departments that
includes everything from museums to job
centers to border Force to ofsted uh
driving instructors it's uh driving
examinations and so on so it could
affect an awful lot of people the union
the PCS they say they're wanting 10 that
haven't been offered anything there that
would say anything less would be
effectively job cut them lots of
protection of jobs protection your
pensions as well potentially the biggest
impact that this strike could have now
is uh border force uh then the we have
seen them strike before we saw them
strike before Christmas we saw members
of the arms Services brought in there to
help out at various centers particularly
the the border crossings over into
France and that will be the case again
today but the advice of course as always
with these Silver Strike actions might
be difficult to get away anyway because
of what's happening with the rail
strikes but if you are planning on going
abroad or if you have got people coming
back into this country they may face
some significant delays at the
okay and uh finally down where you are
yeah morning K we're outside clinician
High School in Cardiff it is one of
around 23 000 schools that is impacted
by strike action today it will see
around a hundred thousand teachers right
across England and here in Wales walk
out in a row over pay now the
government's in both countries and Wales
and England are urging schools to try
their best to stay open but there is
clearly going to be a significant impact
some schools just openly opening
partially with certain year groups
coming in on that of course is a huge
impact for parents who are having to
figure out child care right up and down
the land uh today this as I say is in a
route of a pay and outside this school
later we are expecting a picket line to
form with members of the National
Education Union this is the first of
seven days of strike action being
carried out this month and next month by
school teachers the next strike is
taking place on the 14th of February and
that only impacts schools here in Wales
okay thanks to all of you I know you're
going to update us throughout the course
of the morning thank you
and we have all the union bosses on the
program as well this morning on a
special morning of coverage on the
biggest strikes in a decade and if you
scan the QR code on your screen right
now
here it comes you can listen to this
morning's Daily News podcast as the
country faces the biggest day of
industrial action in a decade
also coming up on the program for you
this morning a four-year-old girl has
died after being attacked by a dog at a
property in Milton Keynes Belize have
described it as a tragic incident and
say the child's family is being
supported by specially trained officers
police will call shortly after five
o'clock last night after a report that a
dog had attacked a child in the back
Garden of a property in the netherfield
area of the city the child died at the
scene shortly afterwards no arrests have
been made
in a statement police said this is an
absolutely tragic incident in which we
believe that a child has been killed
after being attacked by a dog clearly we
are in the very early stages of an
investigation and it would be wrong and
unhelpful to speculate as to the exact
circumstances of this incident at this
point
internet personality Andrew Tate is due
in court in Romania today alongside his
brother Tristan to appeal against their
detention the British American Nationals
have been held in custody for more than
a month of allegations of rape and human
trafficking which they deny well joining
us uh now is Siobhan in Romania's
capital of Bucharest
um hello to you Siobhan tell us more
good morning
morning K I'm at the back of the court
because in the last 15-20 minutes we've
seen both of the Tate brothers and two
Romanian women who were arrested
alongside them arriving here in court
Andrew Tate as he went into the back
door there saying you know I'm innocent
and today his lawyers will again be
trying to get him and his brother
released after they were arrested at the
end of December
um looking at looking at an
investigation into human trafficking
also allegations of rape and as part of
that investigation police have seized an
estimated four million dollars worth of
money and goods from a property
connected to the brothers they have
denied all of the allegations against
them they have said that they need to be
released at the moment though just in
the last couple of weeks a court here
actually extended their detention as
police continue to investigate so as it
stands they're due to stay in detention
and until at least the 27th of February
that is what their lawyers will be
trying to overturn today okay for now
Siobhan thank you
also making news for you this morning
police have been alerted over claims
that Dorset and Wiltshire firefighters
photographed dead bodies of women in car
accidents it's reported that images were
shared on a WhatsApp group and that male
firefighters made comments about the
type of underwear the victims were
wearing
Dorset and Wiltshire fire service has
commissioned an independent
investigation into the claims and says
it shocked and appalled by the
allegations
of course that story will be developing
during again the course of the morning
at meantime the United States is
preparing more than two billion dollars
worth of military aid for Ukraine which
is expected to include longer range
weapons for the first time it comes as
Ukraine is preparing for a major
escalation by Russia let's get the
latest should we Deborah standing by for
us at the scene in uh Kiev this morning
again
um so more is coming their way they
wanted these long-range missiles
um but they want aircraft as well
they want Jets they need these tanks
that they've been promised to come
online faster because they're expecting
that there's going to be much more
fighting ahead in fact I spoke to the
president's top security official Alexi
danilov yesterday and he said to me that
they believe that the hardest fighting
Is Yet To Come And they also expecting
potentially for that fighting to begin
rather sooner than later this is what he
had to say
foreign
for new offensives themselves he
wouldn't go into details about that it
must be said though that a western
official speaking to journalists
yesterday said that they didn't believe
that well they hadn't seen any specific
signs of Russia planning anything around
the 24th of February but they're keeping
monitoring that noting that Russia does
quite like making uh making actions
around specific dates so really here
right now the fighting raiding in the
East and expectation that it's going to
get worse
okay for now thank you
still to come on the program for you
this morning joined by the General
Secretary of the trades Union Congress
Paul Novak ahead of today's Nationwide
protests over the government's
anti-strike legislation
as a hundred thousand civil servants
strike I'll speak to Mark Sir Walker the
General Secretary of the public and
Commercial Services Union
eight joined by the shadow Justice
secretary Steve Reed
UK government has been too slow in
addressing the challenges of climate
change and will need to invest billions
of pounds to prepare for the impacts of
a warming climate the independent
climate change committee says 10 billion
pounds a year will be required as part
of a major program of investment to
prepare the UK for the impacts of
climate change it says the country must
prepare for flooding and proofing houses
and infrastructure against its impacts
investment will also have to be made to
protect the public water supply and in
nature restoration
let's get more about that should we our
Science and Technology editor Tom Clark
joins us on the program this morning hi
it's good to see you tell us more about
this report well this is the stuff that
we already are going to have to do to
cope with the climate change that's
coming you know we we hear a lot about
what the government's doing to reduce
the likelihood of climate change
building more wind turbines switching
yourself fossil fuels what the committee
on climate change is saying the
government's made it clear it's got a
plan for that it's got a clear pathway
of how it's going to phase out fossil
fuels and switches over all that could
be arguably doing better and getting us
there but when it comes to adapting to
the climate change we're all going to
sit already going to see they've got a
lot more work to do there isn't a clear
plan of action there isn't really much
of a plan in place at all the government
respond they have got an adaptation plan
coming out later this year but there are
some important things that needs to
include this report says you know how
are you going to make the money flow to
finance these things they say a lot of
it doesn't need to be new money although
there is a lot of money how much is it
going to cost
they estimate it's not unreasonable they
say about 10 billion pounds a year and
that's every year going on through the
rest of this Century take homes for
example they're saying at least a
billion a year might be needed to make
our housing
cope better in the heat remember the
heat waves we had last year really put a
lot of this in very uncomfortable houses
very high heat I think we had nearly 3
000 excess deaths last summer because of
excess heat so there's cost there but
they say not all of this money has to
come from the taxpayer a lot of it is
just about diverting flows of existing
money to factor in the fact climate
change is going to be happening so for
example you have flood protection making
room for water to go when we get extreme
rainfall or when the council's doing up
the road make a plan for where the
rainfall is going to go while you're
doing the improvements because we are
looking at decades worth of time scales
um thanks a lot speak to you more
throughout the course of the morning
thank you meantime parts of the world uh
experiencing extreme weather conditions
as well let's have a look at the impact
of climate change on the planet the
right half
um of oh this is our obviously our
indicator it was broken for a bit it's
fixed again now we love showing you
these figures in the morning quite often
it's not nil for uh 1.7 percent to today
Renewables are heading towards
two-thirds gas ten and a half percent
the top one is how much higher it is the
temperature now than 1880 and this is
how much CO2 emissions are taking
now
U.S Secretary of State Anthony blinken
has wrapped up a two-day visit to Israel
and the occupied West Bank after one of
the deadliest outbreaks of
israeli-palestinian violence in years
first and foremost
diffusing the current uh situation the
current cycle of violence reducing
tensions not escalating them
calming things down not ramping things
up that is the um the immediate focus
and I heard both from
Palestinians including president Abbas
as well as from Israelis some ideas for
how that how we can move that forward my
hope is that
if that succeeds then we can look to
both sides to take some positive steps
to try to rebuild confidence rebuild
Trust
and that in turn lays the foundation for
at some point
pursuing two states
well joining us now is our Middle East
correspondent Alistair bunkel standing
by in Jerusalem hi Alistair he's gone
home what's he achieved
well look firstly I would say that I
think there were some messages to the
Israeli government particularly when it
comes to internal matters like judicial
reform which is a big big thing here for
many Israelis we've seen uh tens of
thousands out on the streets and it's
something that America clearly opposes
so I think it was messages to the
Israeli government in private and in
public on that as for the increasing
violence uh between Israelis and
Palestinians Anthony binkum was treading
um a very thin line a very difficult
line uh to balance the two America are a
very strong Ally of Israel and they are
to some degree clearly engage what is
going on here but I don't think that
this American Administration this white
house administration you know sees
what's going on here as one of their
main priorities at the moment and we
heard nothing new from Anthony blink
when he was over here there were no sort
of new grand ideas of how to break the
impasse talk of a two-state solution
which diplomats not just in America but
around the world have always sort of
clung on to as an ambition it's just so
far down the road from where the
situation is right now it's not a
realistic Prospect and I think the other
really great concern is that in the
current Israeli government there are
figures who don't want to step back they
want to push they want more settle
expansion and they want to push into
Palestinian land
and that means that this situation
remains very volatile I think education
secretary Jillian Keegan is in the Pro
in the studio on the program for us now
good morning good morning good morning
see you as always how many schools are
closed or partially closed today well we
don't know that we'll know later on
today and we'll publish that uh this
afternoon
um we have done a survey which a lot of
heads responded to
um so that gives us some idea and that
said the majority just said the majority
of schools would be open but we've got
yes open but we've got you know how many
are open then how many open with some
restrictions and how many open to
everybody
um obviously we're really disappointed
that any are closing but um we will know
later on today and then we'll publish
that information okay I was speaking to
uh The Joint head of the Neu Union
um and he says that there was not when
he came in to see you the minister
brought no proposals whatsoever to the
table nothing on pay this year or next
no suggestion of non-consolidated lump
sum no pay rise what's the point calling
them in
well we need to continue these
discussions so I've met with them now
since the ninth since the 9th of January
I've met with them three times uh by the
way for over an hour each time they keep
talking about half an hour meeting but
it was an hour and ten minutes that one
um and we've also had two official
meetings one of which was six hours to
go through all of the details you know
we have to keep these discussions open
obviously when you're around the table
it's not going to be you know here's our
inflationary pay rise plus whatever you
know this is not going to happen it
would be irresponsible of us to do that
so what's the point coming in because we
need to find where there is
um a a landing Zone really so when you
look at teachers and teachers paying
when you actually look at a teacher's
sort of things that irritate teachers or
things that they want changing it's
always a workload
um Behavior sometimes and other aspects
of bureaucracy as well as looking at
paid to make sure that we can recruit
the very best and retain teachers as
well so what we've said to them is look
we cannot
as a country We cannot put um you know
for some parts of society and inflation
or inflation plus rise which you know
many people are striking for what we
have to do is halve inflation that's the
most important thing or get it even
lower than that and then everybody in
the country will benefit we can't bake
in inflation which is what will happen
if we you know we start to get wages uh
spiraling out of control in inflationary
uh or even more than inflation Rises so
that is the huge Focus for this year but
what we've said to them is you know we
accept and we've worked with them a lot
on Recruitment and Retention challenges
in the past we've said you know we will
look at Future pay we will look at
workload we will look at um flexibility
the teachers also want to look at more
job sharing and flexibility we look at
all of those things that's the point of
calling them in because we can we
believe get something which would be
fair to teachers and we're always
looking to be constructive you know we
we want our children to have the best
education in the world that means we
need to attract people into teaching and
we need to retain people and motivate
people as you know okay but you know the
pointy-headed finance people will say
inflation inflation inflation um The
Institute for fiscal stop studies says
that teachers have seen a 13 real-time
loss in pay six thousand pound pay cut
between 2012 and 2022. it's hardly
surprising they're angry well when they
look you know the independent
pay-per-view body when it looks at all
of this it takes nine inputs it looks at
um pay it looks at other people's pay it
looks at you know retention it looks at
recruitment it looks at inflation looks
of all of those things and comes up with
so just so your listeners know the
average classroom teacher is paid 39 500
pounds the uh this year the the pay
Rises were five percent for experienced
teachers 8.9 for new teachers new
teachers will be on a starting salary of
30 000 from September 23. that's as per
our Manifesto commitment 40 of classroom
teachers this year will be receiving up
to a 15.9 percent wise because his way
as well as the pay on the on the bans
there's also progression within the
bands so it's actually more complex and
it is a quite a complex picture we've
also looked at um recruitment challenges
for example maths and physics teachers
and some of the chemist chemistry and
some of the other science teachers
computer science as well and we've put
bursaries in place for those we've also
put a top up for some of those schools
as well some schools in disadvantages
well teach
you know we all every everybody wants to
be paid more you know One is paid enough
I well we look at that we look at that
in terms of recruitment retention and we
look at that in terms of the starting
salary that's why we've improved the
starting salary so it will be thirty
thousand uh
well if it isn't we'll look at it again
but we will we have recruited and
attracted a lot of graduates so 30 000
for somebody coming out of University
you know and that's across the country
um
they keep going on strike we've got uh
several more strikes uh planned if they
don't get what they want um you're
saying strike as much as you want
there's no more money well no what I've
said is it's really disappointing really
concerning this strike is not a last
resort the discussions we had on Monday
were constructive discussions they even
said that at the beginning whilst then
saying I didn't come up with any offers
Etc and that's of course not what's
going to happen I'm not going to just go
in and say here you go we will do
inflation plus whatever
um it would be economically incoherent
to do that we can't do that and we've
made that very clear but we will get
inflation down so everybody will feel
better and then you know we're just
going to run down the clock until
inflation starts no we've said we will
talk about future pay we've actually
held back okay right well it's already
in fact our future pay our submission
was actually due in last Friday and we
we've halted it the next year that's
from April about this year this is when
they want the money well yes and we've
said you know we're looking at Future
pay we'll look at things like workload
but we have said what are what our
objective is this year is to get rid of
the problem which is inflation and we
know why inflation's there right this is
not usual inflation it's very specific
to the war in Ukraine and the overhang
from the pandemic too highly unusual
things that are happening on our
continent and they've affected every
country so we don't want to thank
anybody else's well we don't want to
bake in inflation and we need to get our
economy so that it's better than
everyone else's and I think we can but I
think we can do that you know we Jeremy
laid out his plan and very confident in
our economy I mean you know I've worked
in business before I became a politician
for 30 years in many many sectors I am
very confident about our economy and our
ability so will there be a significant
pay rise next year for them well what we
said is we will look and talk in double
figures no I mean we'll look and talk
what is reasonable to make sure that we
always retain the best teachers and we
attract the best teachers you know we
are to have a world-class education
system you need brilliant teachers
that's something we both agree on but
the other thing we agree on is our
children have been through so much
disruption in the pandemic that you know
it really is
um super concerning for children they're
already behind we need to help them
catch up and that is it needs teachers
to be in school to do running out of
time let me ask you about Dominic Robb
should the PM ask him to step back until
the inquire into his bullying is
concluded well I personally think it is
fair to let investigations continue you
know I think that's the fair process so
I I think actually it was Dom himself
who instigated this investigation so
that's ongoing obviously they're going
to uncover all the facts and then when
you get the facts you you discuss them
take the action what's it like for you
as a woman sitting around a cabinet
table with someone who allegedly makes
his staff feel suicidal I you know I sit
around the cabinet table and you know
don't see don't see that right I don't
see any you know I feel very comfortable
with my colleagues around the cabinet
table I think it's only fair when
somebody is you know there's something
like this somebody excuses somebody of
something that you go through a fair
process I think that is the right thing
to do and then the Prime Minister
um and Dominic will obviously discuss
that and make the right decision based
on that you've got to go on the facts
and they're uncovering the facts right
okay Jacob Reese mogg yesterday sat
there where you are and told us that
people are too snow flaking at about
bullying claims well I mean I don't
agree with that I mean bullying is very
serious and actually you know as the
education Minister one of the things
that really is worrying in schools is
bullying and online as well the the sort
of way that bullying can spiral online
is is awful so I don't agree with that
bullying is wrong and people should not
bully anybody it's good to see thank you
thank you very much for joining us thank
you bear with us one second if you would
looking at some of the front pages for
you this morning uh the telegraph says
there's a chance teachers could still be
paid today even if they participate in
strikes the male calls it a cynical
walkout that betrays our children again
and the sun covers The Disappearance of
mum-of-2 Nicola bully in Lancashire as
police speak to a potentially key
witness quick look at the weather
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
Northstar splitting the weather over the
next few days but it will turn milder
for most windy starts severe Gales
across Northern Scotland bringing some
travel disruption
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
hey good everybody tomorrow is here to
give us her take on what the minister
had to say this morning good morning
morning Kay well if the education unions
had held out much hope for Julian Keegan
making them an offer and I don't think
they did hold out much hope then on
Monday they were rapidly disabused of
that because they had a meeting and left
saying that she had not offered them
anything and what Jillian Keegan told us
we've heard similar from Steve Barkley
who's negotiating with the health unions
is that yes they're willing to talk
about non-pay issues about burnout about
retention about Workforce about next
year's pay after April but when it comes
to this year's pay essentially forget it
she said they're not going to come in
I'm not going to see them and say right
there you go and even on the prospect of
an inflation level pay rise for next
year and she said sort of 10 was
basically a no so inflation we think is
probably at its peak at the moment it
may go down later this year and I think
for parents who are having to make
alternative arrangements for their
children given the school closures in
England and Wales today it really does
seem clear that these next six strike
dates across England and Wales over the
next six weeks are looking very likely
to go ahead yeah so there's no more
money you can go on strike as much as
you want you're not getting any more
money it does seem to be the message
that in terms of this year's pay the
government think the government feel on
firmer ground with teachers than they do
for example with nurses as a noticeable
difference where Julian Keegan says that
teachers got five percent last year
above other parts of the public sector
and that the the most Junior teachers
are going to be starting on thirty
thousand pounds from later this year as
part of a government commitment so they
feel that teachers have in context of
the public sector done okay and it
doesn't feel like they want to negotiate
higher there okay for now thanks very
much thank you
Nationwide protests are being held today
by the trades Union Congress over the
government's controversial new
legislation on strikes this is the
picket line in Cardiff as we speak we
have our correspondents and reporters
right around the country and of course
we'll be catching up with them all day
here on Sky News don't forget of course
that March later on today on to
Parliament the General Secretary of the
tuc's with me now good morning morning
um sorry Mr Novak tell me about the
March later on okay well this will be
March part of our wider series of
activities that are being held today too
support our campaign to protect the
right to to strike but also to stand up
for our public services and support
those hundreds of thousands of public
sector workers who are taking strike
action today around paying that have
been taken strike action over the last
few few weeks a month so this is part of
our whole series of activity up and down
the country and we hope that the
governments will take it seriously and
listen to the voices of working people
why do you think they will well I I
would hope that any employer would have
the good grace in the sense to listen to
the staff when the staff tell them that
there's a problem and there clearly is a
problem it doesn't matter whether it's
teachers civil servants physiotherapists
paramedics uh lots of workers saying we
can't afford another year of a real
Thames pay cut now as I say okay I would
expect any employer to say well listen
let's listen to your concerns let's
respond to those concerns and let's try
and deliver a fair pay rise and up until
now unfortunately the government hasn't
done that but I'm an optimist and I'm a
negotiator and I hope that the
government will listen and we'll come to
the table um education secretary sat
there a moment ago she said do what you
want there's no more money well you know
government is all about political
choices and I'm afraid this government
has made the wrong choices now uh Julian
Keegan is right to a certain extent uh
it's rissy schumach and Jeremy Hunt that
needs to make the money available to
fund a decent pay rise and so far the
Prime Minister and his Chancellor have
been missing in action I think last
summer was on your program uh two or
three weeks ago I said that we wanted to
sit down with the chancellor and the PM
to talk about what could be done in
terms of fair pay settlement new money
on the table we haven't had a response
well I'm not interested in beer and
sandwiches or indeed Italian sympathy
what I'm interested in doing is
resolving these disputes but resolving
them in a way that puts money in the
pockets of all those public sector
workers who say they can't afford
another real Thames uh pay cut and that
you know we've talked in the past about
the Staffing crisis in our NHS 300 000
vacancies into Care Homes and in the NHS
we've got a staffing crisis in our
classrooms as well I mean a third of
teachers around a quarter of a million
of them have left the profession within
10 years of qualifying that's a problem
for for our school tools and it's a
problem for the education of our kids so
the government has to do something
that's not just respond to those issues
well it's it's partly about money it's
partly about things like workload uh but
you know what is being addressed by the
education secretary well I I don't think
the reality is you can't resolve issues
around workload Recruitment and
Retention and not talk about pay at the
same time and that's where I think the
governments are playing a little bit
fast and loose with the British public
to say somehow these things aren't
connected they're absolutely connected
and really the government needs to sit
down as I say the Prime Minister and the
chancellor come to the table find some
new money
um yeah well they say there isn't any
more money the nurses want more money
the ambulance workers want more money
the train drivers want more money these
civil servants want more money border
control wants more money in what order
should people be getting money well it's
important to sort of differentiate so
for example the train drivers are
working for private companies those
companies have handed out hundreds of
millions of pounds in dividends to their
shareholders I think they could afford a
payroll for their train drivers well
actually it's not about this group of
workers is more deserving than the other
what we need is to see pay Rising across
the public and indeed the private sector
now what could the government do about
this the TUC will put in its budget
submission today we'll be at the
treasury today to put in our budget
submission and we'll be saying that the
government could for example choose the
taxi offshore uh the oil and gas giants
more heavily they could use to equalize
capital gains tax with income tax tax
wealth in the same way they tax workers
that alone would generate another 15 or
16 billion pounds so government is all
about choices unfortunately this is
governments has made the wrong choices
well they are going to wear you down
basically and it's going to get to April
and then they're going to say that was
last year third year money we're talking
about next year now well I hope that's
not the attitude to be honest with you
the the wearing down not just unions
they're wearing down the British public
I mean I think and I've been on the
picket lines with our physiotherapists
with our paramedics uh when the public
are going past beeping the horns talking
to those workers showing their support I
think they're very clear whose side the
British public are on and I hope the
government listens to that you know in
the problem not necessarily the case
promises we've been doing this long
enough to know what's going on and there
will be some support for uh our NHS but
the other unions that the government is
going to wait until the public turns
against them well I I think I think
they'll be waiting a long time to be
honest with okay I mean it's clear we
did a poll uh just last week that a
majority of parent support teachers take
in a strike action but at the end of the
day these are I mean these are our
friends our neighbors members of our
local community everybody knows a
teacher somebody who works in the NHS
somebody who works on the railways and I
think trying to the government trying to
divide the British public away from
striking workers I think won't won't
succeed because those striking workers
are part of the local community they've
got those you know the face of those
public services and I want the
government to treat them with respect
and deliver a decent pay rise how many
people have to take part in the march
today for it to be deemed as success
well it's not it's it's not a big
National rally because obviously we do
have the train strikes so we're not
bringing people in from all over the the
country the key thing is we've got 80
events up and down the country plenty of
opportunities for people to show the
support and later on I'll be handing in
a petition with a quarter of a million
signatures to down the street about the
protecting the right to strike and I
think the government should listen to
people power listen to public opinion
deliver on pay yeah but if you you you
know if you've got a dozen people with a
bull horn and a dog turning up to
Parliament the government are going to
use that as an illustration as to why
you don't have any support yeah well I I
don't think it will be a dozen people
what I think they should be looking at
the fact is that half a million workers
today will be taking strike action and
that's on top of the hundreds of
thousands have already taken strike
action hundreds of thousands potentially
more to come over the next few weeks and
months they should look at that quarter
of a million signatures they should look
at those events up and down the country
and they should realize they've
misjudged the public mood and I hope
that they do and I hope that they come
to the table do you think there'll be
another national day of action uh well I
I mean I wouldn't rule anything out uh
uh okay my responsibility is to when
workers take that really difficult
decision to take strike action that we
support them as much as possible that we
amplify their voices and I think you
know the ball is very firmly in the
government's Court let's get round the
table let's resolve these disputes and
let's put money in the pockets of our
hard work and public service workers
good to see you as always thank you very
much for taking the time I know you've
got a busy day thank you
um of course we will be uh monitoring
that March as it heads towards
Parliament later on putting up the sky
copter and we're at picket lines up and
down the country as well what are your
views let us know you can tweet us
directly if you would like to at kberley
do do the unions have your support or do
you agree with the government there just
isn't the money in the pot now a record
number of Elton John fans will be
rocking away at his farewell tour
Crocodile Rock
[Music]
yellow brick road tour has become the
highest grossing of all time raking in a
whopping
664 million pounds
he's even topped Guns and Roses you two
and Ed Sheeran after kicking off the
tour in 2018 Elton will play his final
UK show at Glastonbury in June
time now for a look through some of the
photos that have caught our eye today a
picture of a Priceless gold pendant
dating back to the Tudor era 16th
century artifact was allegedly used to
celebrate the first of Henry VII's
marriages to Catherine of Aragon found
in Warwickshire by a metal detectorist
only six months into his hobby good for
him
you'll never find anything as good as
that mate now next up thousands of
people converged in Shetland for a
viking inspired fire Festival it's
Europe's largest fire festival and this
year for the first time and it's 142
year history women and girls were
allowed to take part in the celebration
and members of a Brazilian Samba School
rehearsing the streets of Rio De Janeiro
ahead of their annual Carnival parade
you're under 100 000 civil servants are
on strike today including union members
in 124.
separate government departments Mark
sawatka is the General Secretary of the
public and Commercial Services Union
representing those walking out with us
now as you can see hi good to see you
thanks for joining us was this really
necessary
unfortunately it was necessary and the
Civil Service have had the lowest pay
award anywhere in the economy two
percent even though inflation is at 10
and food inflation is at 16. we've tried
for months to get the government to
engage in discussions and they're not
even prepared to put money on the table
at the moment even though it's now been
revealed that in two government
departments alone DWP and the tax
offices 47
000 people will get a pay raise on the
first of April because they're now on
the national minimum wage so people who
are delivering key decisions across a
range of Public Services have had their
pay cut for 10 consecutive years now
qualify for the national minimum wage so
there's a crisis of inward poverty forty
thousand civil servants using food banks
forty five thousand civil servants are
claiming in-work benefits the very
definition of the inwork poor but the
government seems happy to give its own
Workforce
far less even than everyone else has
been offered and has rejected into going
on strike over so this is necessary I'm
afraid where's the money going to come
from to give you any more money
well we clearly think there's lots of
money available to be frank it's a
matter of political priority the
government claim it would cost I think
29 billion to give every public sector
worker what they've asked for our
calculations is actually would cost near
a 10 billion if you take into account
the tax and insurance that is paid and
10 billion pounds in an economy like
ours can easily be found and we know
that this government in the form of Liz
truss a conservative government was
prepared to borrow 200 billion pounds
for tax cuts so it's a matter of if they
prioritize paramedics job center workers
and Border force staff or they're happy
to see those people claim benefits and
use food banks this is a list of what
you're looking for from the government
the
I suppose a Chancellor and thus the
Prime Minister would say to you in
response we cannot do this because it
will fuel inflation
well I don't think any serious Economist
believes that the current inflation is
anything to do with pay
and our view is the Bank of England is
trying to cut the inflation Target but
the bank of England is also worried
about a recession we narrowly missed a
recession last time
most people accept that if you're going
into a recession the last thing you want
is for people to be impoverished and
have no money to spend we need people to
be able to support the hospitality
sector the manufacturing sector and if
PCS members were to get a pay raise I
can say to UK they would not be putting
it in the Cayman Islands or tax-free
Investments they would spend it because
people are desperate and in our view
that has a boosting effect on the
economy and it is something that could
easily be afforded and economically
would be a wise thing to do which
departments how will my viewers at home
this morning be affected will there be a
lot of effects today it's a one-day
strike so job centers will be closed
today there's already picket lines at
our airports and our ports museums and
galleries will be closed passport
offices will be closed the driving and
vehicle license agency will be closed
the Welsh Parliament for example can't
sit today the Scottish Parliament will
be seriously disrupted so across all
parts of government life there will be
picket lines today and there will be no
public service and that's for one day
but we've also announced that because
this can't just be about a protest
there's going to be a week of strike
action at the British museum there's
going to be four days of strikes at the
borders including Dover and Calais and
Dunkirk and that's going to involve
significant disruption so our message to
the government
is rather than just duck this rather
than accept all this disruption you must
accept there is an economic and moral
case to say we cannot have civil
servants claiming the benefits they
administer visiting food banks and
Beyond the national minimum wage
it looks as though I mean certainly from
what we heard from the education sector
this morning they're not going to budge
they're not going to budge do you
anticipate another day of action when
half a million workers will be on strike
I anticipate there'll be more than that
the next time I think there's a day of
action because the government's position
is unsustainable now let's be clear they
do u-turns at a pretty rapid rate we've
seen Richie soon outdo a number of
u-turns it's not feasible that they can
sit back with this unprecedented amount
of industrial action growing because
it's half a million today next week we
have paramedics and we have nurses they
will then be the firefighters we know
we've now voted for strike action so the
amount of people taking or voting for
Action is going to grow and I don't
believe the government will find it can
get away with putting its head down
while all this disruption takes place
and I think they'll be forced to take a
much more realistic attitude but if they
refuse
we are planning for our campaign to
continue right through the summer with
both long-term sustained targeted
strikes but also Mass actions like today
and I think we will see if there is
another one it will be even bigger than
the one today and when do you think
anticipate that might happen
well this strikes next week as we know
um we know that the teachers unions for
example have announced two days of
strike action in March one of those days
is uh on budget day and I think it would
be a fair guess to say that lots of
unions will be looking to see whether
that is a really good time for us to
come back together
but that's a long time away okay and if
Richie sunac is watching your program or
Jeremy Hunt well they both do good
morning I I think they need to realize
that they can't get away with this they
cannot have this inward poverty in this
country at this level and they kind of
have the disruption that we're seeing
and they're going to have to do
something about it and the sooner they
get on and do that the better so just to
clarify you're saying that if the
the government doesn't come back with
more money an offer of a decent amount
of money in your opinion than in six
weeks time we will see more than 500 000
workers on strike all on the same day
I'm saying that if the government
refused to improve any offers and
doesn't put money on the table there
will be more and more strikes and given
we already know that the teachers have
already announced a two-day strike in
the 15th and 16th of March I think it's
very likely that other unions May well
take the same decision our Union's
national executive committee will meet
next week and we will take a decision on
future action and that will be one of
the things that we'll be discussing what
do you need what what can the government
do in order to stop that
money now we cannot have a situation
where they tell us you just have to wait
I mean our 2023 pay which they tell us
to wait for in some cases isn't due till
August I mean to be honest the energy
bills are going up in April the crisis
is now and we need money now and we've
made that absolutely clear but we also
need in the Civil Service an agreement
they're not going to cut the tens of
thousands of jobs they're threatening to
cut they're not going to cut our members
redundancy terms okay by a staggering 33
is the cuts they want to make they want
to make tens of thousands redundant and
cut their contractual redundancy by a
third and also yesterday we're in the
high court because they know that our
pensions are currently unfair and we're
paying too much for our pensions despite
an independent public sector valuation
so in short treat us with the dignity
and respect we deserve we were clapped
in the pandemic now give us money to
avertise 30 seconds to offer one final
word for uh Jacob reesemug who said we
don't need this many civil servants
what we don't need is they could be
smoke